An experience beyond limits... pain and pleasureindivisible.
This is the
untold truth of "Hellraiser."
What's in a name? Well, quite a lot when it
comes to a movie. Just imagine if "Toy Story"
had been called "Toyz in the Hood," "Alien"
had been called "Star Beast," or "Back to the
Future" had been called "Spaceman from Pluto" —
because they all almost were. Would these films
still have gone on to be box-office smashes and
critical faves? We'll never know. But what we
do know is that "Hellraiser" was very nearly
called "Sadomasochists From Beyond the Grave."
Clive Barker explained in a 1987
interview with Fangoria that he
originally wanted "Hellraiser" to have
a very different title. He revealed —
"The imagery we're employing is,
as far as the creatures from hell
are concerned, something that hasn't been
done before. They're like sadomasochists
from beyond the grave. In fact, that's what
I originally wanted to call the picture."
As far as titles go, it's certainly a bit beyond
the pale, and definitely a lot different from
"The Hellbound Heart," the title of the
novella that inspired the film. Still,
if there was ever to be a gang name that nailed
the vibe that Pinhead, Butterball, and the rest
of the cenobites give off, "Sadomasochists
From Beyond the Grave" is perfectly spot on.
Alongside Leatherface, Michael Myers,
Freddy Krueger, and Pennywise, Pinhead
is an almost universally recognizable villain
and an iconic embodiment of '80s horror.
It might be surprising, then, that in the first
"Hellraiser" films, he's not technically a bad
guy — just an infernal ambassador who takes his
job extremely seriously. According to his creator,
though, the moniker "Pinhead" doesn't
exactly do the character justice.
Clive Barker explained in an interview with
Dread Central that the character was a priest
of hell who remained nameless
in the original script. However,
a special effects artist referred to him as
"Pinhead," and that was that. Barker recalled —
"I was like, 'Wait a second, you
just named my villain Pinhead?'
I didn't think that sounded very dignified. But
it ended up on the call sheet, and it just stuck."
"Who you callin' 'Pinhead?'"
Before the release of "Hellraiser,"
no one realized how popular the guy
with nails in his face would end up being.
The hell priest wasn't even the original
poster boy for the film: Pinhead actor
Doug Bradley told HorrorOnline.com that
a flayed Frank was originally the image
intended to grace posters and lunchboxes.
At some point during production, the powers
that be opted for the grid-faced man to push
the film into the darkest corners of the
public consciousness. Bradley explained —
"The image is so original, so startling.
It is just an incredible image to look at,
and that made a big difference in terms
of the public's perception of the movie."
On one level, "Hellraiser" is a cautionary tale
about what happens to a curious individual when
he meddles in the supernatural. In another
sense, if you look past the flesh flaying,
the screams, the carnage, and the sadist
with pins in his face, you'll find what
Clive Barker has referred to as "a love story
from beyond the grave." It might sound absurd,
but take a closer look and you'll see that
Barker isn't wrong. The author explained that
just as it's desire that leads Frank Cotton
to a lonely place where he's skinned alive,
it's the same desire that leads his brother's
wife, Julia Cotton, down the road to ruin.
Julia attempts to resurrect her old
lover by butchering unsuspecting men
so Frank can feed on their precious
blood, but as Barker points out,
she doesn't do it because she's a psychopath
— she does it for love. Barker stressed in
the same interview that he intended "Hellraiser"
to be an "intelligent and popular horror movie"
that didn't exploit women or manipulate
sensibilities. He told Monsterland —
"There has been a general move towards
the infantile in horror pictures recently,
a desire to soften the blows. I hope this
time we're going to get tough again."
Let's be honest — the Cenobites are a pretty
eye-catching bunch. If Pinhead and his posse
strutted into a party, it would certainly cause
a stir. Their look is hellish, and with all the
leather and boots it's reminiscent of the
weirdest shock rock group never to play a
gig. You wouldn't want to bump into these guys in
a graveyard or an S&M club, the latter of which,
according to Clive Barker, is the inspiration for
the Cenobites' distinctive look. Barker told The
Guardian that both the physical and emotional
make-up of the Cenobites was inspired by S&M
clubs he had frequented, specifically an
underground club in New York called Cellblock 28.
Barker revealed that Cellblock 28 had a hardcore
S&M night where there was no drinking or drugs:
just intense pain, pleasure, and a
whole lot of piercings. He elaborated —
"It was the first time I ever saw people pierced
for fun. It was the first time I saw blood spilt."
"Oh, no tears, please! It's
a waste of good suffering."
Barker explained that the move to make
the cenobites act and dress a certain
way was met with positive reception
from the S&M community, saying —
"I was validating a lifestyle. It was
a celebration of the beauty of
these strange secret rituals."
Having only made a couple of short films with
a group of friends in Liverpool as a teenager,
"Hellraiser" was Clive Barker's first
experience helming a major movie production.
Directing a feature film for the first time was
a daunting task, as he revealed in an interview:
"I didn't know the rules. I didn't know who
the sound guy was. I only knew who the camera
operator was because he was the guy behind the
camera. I don't think that finally hurt the movie.
May have actually been useful because
I sort of made it up as I went along."
When Barker was young, he and a group of friends
grabbed an 8mm camera and shot two shorts,
"Salome" and "The Forbidden," inspired
by underground and experimental directors
like Kenneth Anger. Future Hellraiser
collaborators Doug Bradley and Pete
Atkins were involved in the productions.
Barker reflected on his work by saying —
"They are technically extremely
crude and their storylines obscure.
Actually I think it has a
strange poetry about it."
That "strange poetry," as
well as the themes of pacts,
rituals, killers, and sexuality, have a lot in
common with "Hellraiser" as we know it today.
The puzzle box in "Hellraiser" with which
Frank opens the doors to another dimension
is integral to the franchise's overarching
plot. The peculiar-looking device — also
known as the Lament Configuration
— was described in "The Hellbound
Heart' as one of several in existence that
was created by Frenchman Philip LeMarchand.
One is said to be safely under lock and key in
the basement of the Vatican, another was rumored
to have been in the possession of the Marquis
De Sade during his tenure at the Bastille,
and a third found its way into the
hands of an Englishman named Frank.
"Let me see—"
"No, don't touch it! It's dangerous.
It opens doors."
The inspiration for the puzzle box came from
an unlikely source: Clive Barker's grandfather.
According to an interview with the
podcast The Geek's Guide To The Galaxy,
Barker wanted his characters to access hell
in a unique way. He was eventually drawn to a
childhood memory of an elaborate wooden puzzle
box his grandfather, who was a ship's cook,
brought back from the Far East. Barker recalled
playing with the box a lot as a child. When he
was puzzling about how best his character in "The
Hellbound Heart" could open the doors of Hell,
he remembered his grandfather's box,
and the final piece fell into place.
It's no good sweating buckets to create
a horror film designed to shock and
unnerve the audience if you pay
little attention to the soundtrack:
music adds ambience, atmosphere, suspense, and
dread to a movie. In short, the cenobites can't
exactly share screen time with a Disney-style
soundtrack — it would be terribly unbecoming.
Before "Hellraiser's" release,
industrial band Coil delivered a
sonically charged hellscape of a soundtrack
to accompany Clive Barker's film. However,
it never made the final cut and was replaced
by Christopher Young's more traditional score.
Barker was friendly with the members of Coil,
and felt their unique sound would make a perfect
fit for "Hellraiser." The studio disagreed,
apparently deciding that the soundtrack was
just too unsettling. Anyone familiar with
Coil's work during that period wouldn't have
been surprised — as Barker himself once said —
"Coil is the only group I've heard on disc,
whose records I've taken off
because they make my bowels churn."
However, the truth as to why Coil's "Hellraiser"
soundtrack was never given the green light is
far more pedestrian. Coil's Stephen Thrower
told The Quietus that when Barker asked the
producers for more special effects funding,
they said something along the lines of,
"We didn't think this was going to be
as commercial as it is. Re-shoot those
effects scenes and here's some more money. One
stipulation, we want our man to do the score."
Movie sets are hectic places. Everyone's got a job
to do and everyone's rushing around frantically,
trying not to get in one another's way. Costume
designers, camera operators, production managers,
and boom operators all play their part in a
constant effort to keep things from going off
the rails. On the set of "Hellraiser," they
also had their very own maggot and cockroach
wrangler to keep things in order. It was an
odd job, but a necessary one in a pre-CGI
age where everyone had to get their hands
dirty to create something authentic.
In an interview with Film Threat, Clive Barker
pointed out that being on a movie set for fourteen
straight hours and dealing with thirty different
people, all with equally important jobs to do,
was far more tiring than he had anticipated. But
relief came with the insects: Barker enthused —
"The moments which were really exciting
were the major cockroach scenes,
which I really liked. We had a
roach-wrangler. We had Tupperware,
you know? The ultimate Tupperware container —
your Roach Tupperware Container — in the fridge."
Barker explained that special passports
and visas were needed to import extra
large American cockroaches to the UK. The
crew could only import male cockroaches,
because there was a danger that they
could escape and procreate. Barker joked —
"Somewhere in customs there's
presumably a roach sexer!"
Although many people praised "Hellraiser" upon
its release for breathing new life into the horror
genre, not everyone was won over by Clive Barker's
vision. Famed film critic Roger Ebert gave
"Hellraiser" a paltry half-star review, decrying
it as a dreary sham. He wrote, somewhat viciously,
"This is one of those movies you
sit through with mounting dread,
as the fear grows inside of you that
it will turn out to be feature-length."
He didn't care much for its sequel,
either, which he made clear on his TV show.
"The problem here is that there is
no discernable beginning, middle,
or end to this nightmare, just a series
of disconnected and gruesome scenes."
If that seems a tad harsh, it gets worse
— Ebert questioned the motives of the
audience for going to see the movie
in the first place. In his opinion,
"Hellraiser" contained no surprises or emotional
engagement, and lacked any wit or flair.
Interestingly, Ebert's harsh verdict on the
film appeared to be the opening shot in a war
of words between the legendary critic and Clive
Barker, as chronicled on Ebert's own website.
Years after the release of "Hellraiser,"
Barker would slam the critic for making
the controversial statement that "Video
games can never be art." Barker described
Ebert as "prejudiced," calling him a, quote,
"pompous, arrogant old man." How much bearing
Ebert's notorious review of "Hellraiser" had
on Barker's scathing words we'll never know,
but just as criticism is always subjective,
an artist never forgets a bad review.
Imagine Pinhead and Michael Myers battling it
out in a cinematic crossover along the lines of
"Freddy vs. Jason" or "Alien vs. Predator…"
and then imagine it some more, because it's
never going to happen. However, it nearly did.
Although it probably wouldn't have contained a
lot of small talk between the chief cenobite and
the masked murderer, "Hellraiser vs. Halloween"
was a promising premise nevertheless. Paul Kane's
book, "The Hellraiser Films and Their Legacy,"
reveals that filmmaker Dave Parker once pitched
the idea of a crossover event to Dimension Films.
Parker needed a way to get the two
villains together for a rumble,
so he hatched an origin story in which Myers
is trick-or-treating as a child and receives
a mysterious box from a stranger in black boots.
Upon opening it, the Lord of the Dead possesses
Myers' body and goes on a killing spree.
Since he's possessed by a demonic entity,
Myers cannot be killed until Pinhead shows
up years later. From there, it's game on.
Dimension was excited enough to reach out
to both Clive Barker and John Carpenter,
and penciled in a release date of October
31, 2004. However, not only did the owners
of the "Halloween" movie rights throw shade on
the idea, a poll on the official "Halloween"
website suggested that the majority of fans
didn't want the movie to happen… so it didn't.
One of the most unsettling things
about the cenobites — apart from
their insatiable desire to inflict
pain — is their unnerving silence.
Unwavering eye contact with unreadable yet
intense facial expressions, combined with the
art of keeping your entire body extremely
still, is the embodiment of psychological
intimidation. The cenobites are obvious
masters at it. With the exception of Pinhead,
who's not exactly mister talkative, the rest of
the cenobites in "Hellraiser" are a pretty mute
bunch — even the Chatterer isn't much of a
chatterbox. In total, Pinhead is only in the
original film for eight minutes and doesn't have
a lot of lines. That's why it's no wonder that,
combined with the industrial make-up, Doug Bradley
thought he would be unrecognizable in character.
In an interview with The Guardian,
Bradley explained that he was offered
both the role of Pinhead and
the bit part of a moving man.
He had reservations about playing
a heavily made-up monster, saying —
"Because 'Hellraiser' was my first movie, I
thought it might be a good idea to be on screen
as myself. But it was a brief conversation. There
was no doubt in my mind that this unnamed guy
with the pins in his head had a certain je ne
sais quoi that a mattress-delivery guy didn't."
The first time Bradley saw
himself in the mirror as Pinhead,
he knew he had made the right
decision. He continued —
"I had a sense of majesty. His threat is implied:
Look what I did to myself — now
imagine what I can do to you."
"Trick us again, child, and your suffering
will be legendary… even in hell."